je lui ai dit on va voir si vous avez
une chance de former une famille sur les
radios in vitro dans le placard ou par
amour on les habitués connaissent un
grand classique de l'émission ce que par
un mur je crois que ce soir ça s'impose
est-ce que par amour vous êtes presque à
cacher
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer non parce
que j'aurais peur qu'ils ne tuent voyez
enfin je veux dire j'ai envoyé quelqu'un
qui est vérité je pense que la première
question répondent ont déjà c est ce que
vous êtes prêts temps un amour julie
delpy à vous mettre aux drogues dures
non vous êtes et ce que vous êtes prête
à prendre 17 kg par amour bah oui la bd
du mal est-ce que par amour alors hein
c'est évidemment la question de clotilde
courau qui a épousé cette semaine la
question la princesse a vu ni la
question de la française cette rencontre
fut mannequin français lui les princes
de venise et quand il avait lancé son
parfum tu l'avais dit qu'il était tête
de gondole de tuer
et bien voilà c'est plein de souvenirs
qu'on a on leur souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur aux deux tourtereaux
est-ce que donc comme clotilde courau
vous seriez prête à embrasser cent fois
ses chaussettes sales
pourquoi ça par amour choisit pas vous
savez les salles de bains salle de
chaussures en cuir de prince avec des
chaussettes brodé donc
alors aux voix
ouais vraiment belle julie et moi je me
poserai plus la question à quoi cet in
town où vous refusez tout non non non
j'ai dit oui les choses du bout des oui
comme ça bon alors est-ce que par amour
vous accepteriez julie quelques petites
infidélités
si moi aussi je peux être infidèle oui
sans problème un papa koly cela non
est-ce que vous accepteriez par un mot
qu'il a une maîtresse
ça oui moi ça me pose pas de problème
vous ai trouvé la salle est pas chiant
la fidélité est une chose qui me semble
la traite en fait dans un couple la
mesure où l'on veut que les choses
aillent à la mecque pour les deux à
l'impôt les deux c'est déjà plus un bébé
c'était comme ça ta jean-jacques dans
ton couple vous acceptez des non pas
d'un fil et non non sûrement pas non tu
es capable de tuer un chasseur discret
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prête
à vivre à trois avec sa maîtresse sympa
la mettra sa maison fait la vaisselle
celi toussaint pas vraiment la maîtresse
cool mais déjà je sais pas si
j'accepterais de vivre avec la personne
un hummer le mec des charges j'aimerais
mieux qu'ils vivent ensemble parce que
moi j'ai un appartement séparer voyez
hein
pour moi ça me conviendrait mieux à deux
avec leurs maîtresses n'ont pas du tout
apprécié c'est juste une copine oui
c'est très rare mais non non non non
j'aimerais mieux être seule en fait le
titre
lorsqu il peut aller avec sa maîtresse
vivait avec sa maîtresse là me
dérangerait pas mais pourquoi un chien
des trois mois
compatible avec l'abbé changistes par
amour ah non non fanon bons mais j'étais
tout seul non les clubs échangistes il
ya quelque chose d'un peu cradingue quoi
écouter les gens connaissent pas dit
bonjour partouze il faut connaître les
gens à damas d'où il vient et quelles
sont leurs formations non je suis pas du
tout faire tous d'antenne rien du tout
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
c'est quoi une lettre une esclave
sexuelle magnéto oh oui pendant quelques
temps quand même temps j'ai pas quelques
mois mais pas tant que ça parce que non
non non ça non c'est pas possible non
c'est mal barré très mal barré dernière
question je suis passé le poignard
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vendre votre corps pour lui
non même si tu prétends rien travail
apparemment vous avez vos questions ce
n'est pas ici des questions de la vie
c'est les questions et vous je peux
retourner qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts
à vendre votre corps par amour ouais si
ma femme et je refais un serment
solennel à la maison
oui à jaffa me demande de vendre mon
corps par amour je le fais ok de baiser
avec
les bandes le score
je ne sais pas son à sarkozy par exemple
à s'arrêter
si ma femme me demande je passais
beaucoup mais l'amour voilà il est pas
mal
là bas
m